[Music]
collecting analyzing and interpreting
data is a cornerstone of modern medicine
it helps us improve the lives of people
around the planet by improving how we
prevent diagnose and treat human
diseases as healthcare becomes more
personalized and data-driven there's an
increasing demand for professionals who
can leave the application of data
science and medicine to accommodate this
demand Sanford is now offering a
graduate certificate in epidemiology and
clinical research the certificate is a
four class program that provides
students with the knowledge and skills
essential to evaluate or run
epidemiological or clinical studies the
topics we will cover our study design
statistical analysis with medical
applications the basics of probability
and statistical inference beginning and
intermediate R in SAS programming
critical evaluation of the medical
literature theory of clinical research
and the phases of clinical trials
leaders in the field of Epidemiology
have come together to develop this
curriculum including John Ian V's Rita
pop hats and Victor Henderson along with
myself you will earn the certificate
including Stanford transcript credit
after completing four courses the
program is designed to be completed in
nine months however you may choose to
extend the length to accommodate your
personal needs you can also just take
one course without needing to enroll in
the entire certificate program as part
of this program you'll have access to
the same resources as on campus Stanford
students this includes a teaching
assistant and interaction with the
faculty the real power is going to come
from the marriage of the data science
discipline with the epidemiology
discipline and I think that's where the
future lies and making the true
discoveries that make a real difference
whether you are a data scientist
interested in working in epidemiology an
investigator overseeing a clinical trial
where someone who needs to evaluate
research and data
completing this program will set you
apart as a leader in your industry
[Music]